I'm wearing a sweatshirt with a weird
80s headband to try and cover up the
roots of my extensions so it can only
mean one thing it's time to review
fashion monday night was the Met Gala
Awards wasn't an award show I don't know
that I want anything you don't know what
the Met Gala is every year it's kind of
this fashion extravaganza it's a lot I
think that's what it says on the invite
you are invited to the Met Gala for
morning
it's a lot celebrities and designers and
all sorts of people show up
in New York at the Met and they try to
out fashion each other and every year
there's a theme
this year's theme China through the
looking-glass China ah nope the glass
wasn't dirty so let's start reviewing
some fashion yeah goose also had a lot
of opinions
Rihanna I mean she stuck to the MEK on
the logline that's a lot there are
probably a lot of homeless people in
China that could use the hundreds of
comforters you could make out of that
dress but she's Brianna
we would be bored if she didn't do this
right this is what we expect this is
what we hope for she understands what
her relationship is to us and it's this
Beyonce hey girl
doesn't look as good on me as it does on
you and I should have known that I'll be
I'll say this I'm speechless Kim
Kardashian and Kanye West I think they
look fine
I see China through the looking-glass no
but I think I'm seeing a vagina through
the looking-glass Hey sorry for this
sweaty interruption I was just jogging
after I'd filmed this whole video and I
was thinking about Kim Kardashian and
remembered that she released that new
book that she has called selfie where
it's just a series of selfies and then I
remember
announced my second book on Monday and
then I remembered audible.com is
something that I am affiliated with if
you don't know it is a website for
audiobooks they have over 150,000
audiobooks and they're fantastic with
their selection I don't know that
selphie will be on this election but my
book my first one Grace's guide the art
of pretending to be a grown-up is there
and I have currently downloaded Paper
Towns written by John Green the movie is
coming out very soon I should read the
book before I watch the movie I just
want to let you guys know if you use
audible.com/tyleroakley
look at Kim's book I don't know sorry I
just thought of all those things while I
was jogging audible.com slash Grace your
first download is free ok back to the
video that you were watching thanks
Kendall Jenner
okay yeah I really I like this I feel
like kendall Jenner was like in Malibu
and ocean and got stuck in like a
fisherman's net it was like oh no I
can't get out of here Kylie just pour
some glitter on me and we'll go we're
running late cute Lady gaga I really
expected nothing less and I'm so I'm so
happy by this I felt Lady Gaga on
Instagram and she mentioned that she
didn't realize she took three Aleve PMS
to deal with the headache that the
Crown's that she's wearing caused so she
was just walking around all night on
cold medicine been Lady gaga I can't
imagine it was much different from
regular Lady Gaga but we could eat off
that chest plate that gross Jennifer
Lawrence Jennifer Lawrence is like I
don't play that overcompensated game
this is as daring as I get deal with it
Miley Cyrus is it bad that I like this
helps zoe kravitz we get it you're so
cool you're wearing chainmail
do I see China I don't care you're cool
Katy Perry I thought it was Christian or
for a second it's Katy Perry and I think
it's very Katy Perry her purse was a
spray paint can
shopping Michaels enough to appreciate
that now Solange Knowles Danny do you
see Donnie Darko when that weird like
goopy time warp tunnel would come out of
his chest area yeah yeah Robert
Pattinson and fka twigs is that Hugh
cerium colleagues fka twigs the kid
wakes Pickett twigs
I don't know I'm very not cultured in
culture they are a happy couple and her
dressing me like her so much more
because she's got a dick on her thigh I
don't know that there's anyone else in
the world that could stand next to
Robert Pattinson and be so confident
with a wiener on their thigh Carla tell
me John's nick kara debonair horrid al
vagina just so cool so cool that I can
remember how to pronounce your name even
though John Greene told me very much
exactly how to pronounce it see Austin
twins where have you guys been oh just
in a dark place
chiseling your cheekbones got it you
guys look great Sarah Jessica Parker we
can't hit here still there
it's good it's good
well there you go there is a brief
analysis review of the red carpet
fashions at the Met Gala they definitely
happened I hope you like this if you
didn't I don't know don't forget that
mamrie Hart Hannah Hart and I are doing
the no filter tour in New York
Philadelphia Seattle Chicago and San
Francisco links for tickets are down
below get them now they're selling out
really quickly and it's for memory
hearts book tour why dad book calm feels
is so powerful and confident her body
defies gravity things should be sagging
at this point I would assume but not
Beyonce's body Beyonce's body is like
science watch this perky boobs perky
butt scientists would be flabbergasted
but they're too busy dealing with your
boners